I mean,
that shows.
So also because they said earlier,
the mood is so bad,
but the situation is actually good.
Of course,
if they look at the German stock index,
if they look at the 40 companies,
the mood is.
They're paying more dividends this year than ever before.
But that is not the German economy,
but the German economy is what we just heard.
The German economy is medium-sized businesses
and many are in pretty darn dirty shape.
They have to really fight.
And this is also because politics has repeatedly given the wrong course.
And there are the high energy prices.
Point there are uh requirements,
which were just in the traffic light time again so really overboard,
goes my role.
But what is more decisive for me,
are just really very large income from assets.
Many people make their money work for themselves and
have very very high incomes from it,
often just inherited it.
And others who get up every day,
work hard every day,
are burdened with very very heavy taxes and duties,
and that is simply unfair.
I,
I wish that we have a reasonable government here in our country,
which above all really represents the interests of the people of our country.
The federal government does not,
of course.
And certainly you can say uh,
that's uh now,
very very hard tobak.
But I mean,
that's how many feel and that's not just 1st feeling.
I also wanted to like what they said earlier,
that there is n feeling of dissatisfaction or 1.
Feeling that you are not heard.
It is quite real that people feel it in their wallets that they are not heard,
that politicians ignore them and their needs.
There are simply more and more people who have to limit themselves.
They barely make ends meet with their income,
they have existential fears.
This is real,
it has something to do with real distribution.
That's not just the 1st feeling.
Yes.
And this is the result of a policy that has been made.